options
for that
thank you very much for coming for the
last part of today so I'm going to about
my result a new lower bound and
demonization for 830 and the
generalization Centric view on the
algorithmic method
so here's the plan for today's talk
so first I will review some backgrounds
uh can you hear me by the way I agree
and also feel free to interrupt me if
you have any questions so first I will
reveal some backgrounds on such a lower
bounds and the algorithmic method
and then I will describe my results
perspective on the algorithmic method
and also some new result which can be
proved following this perspective
finally I'll give some proof overview
so let's get started
so
he has a over simplified history and
motivation for studying circular bonds
so
since 1980s people wanted to prove MP is
not equal to MP we are proving lower
bounds for stronger and stronger
circular classes
and the the first thing people look at
is constant depth circuits and the
people first started
zero which is constant depth and or not
circuits of unbounded effects
and I uh
very important amount of work prove that
the part for example the parity function
is harder for ss0 so now we have very
good lower bounds for ac0
then the the natural next step to do is
to strengthen the second class for
example you can Aid parity that has a
function back into the second cast so
now parity becomes trivial so now
802 so the question becomes can you
prove lower bounds against XL2
another last word proved that for
example the most three function is
harder for s02 using the using the
polynomial method
method
and uh what's what's more three I'm
going to say for for any integer P model
p is the function which outputs one if
and only if P does not divide the number
of ones in the input
I'm not so if it's more a tool if it's
pirate
and uh of course the next logical thing
to do is you add more 3 to the to the
gift set now you have a class called 806
uh
why why is episode 6 is because having
mode 6 is equivalent to having both
model 3 and the model 2. you can compute
multi mod 3 by padding mode 6 and the
vice versa
uh so now we have now we arrive at 806
which seems I mean it's very natural to
educate get that to the to the the
previous classes
and it seems to them be much stronger
than s02
but unfortunately it has been open for
two decades whether even an x a gigantic
class which is non-seministic
exponential time contains a function
that cannot be completed by even
polynomial size steps three is those six
circuits
so progress basically stopped here for a
long time until so in 2011 are Williams
who is who's there I guess so he proved
that next time it's a little circuits
and I thought okay what's exercise
better so we use ac0m so just like s06
and SL2 with wheels slm to denote
constant depth and or not mod M sockets
and I say zero is simply the union of
h0m for our constant n so you first fix
that constant and then you can use the
mode M gate
so that's some subsequent subsequent
work following Williams breakthrough
so
so in 2018 Murray and Williams proved
that and kill P which is non-demnistic
quasi polynomial time so this one is
much smaller than an X
so it's much closer to MP it does not
have polynomial effects as low circuits
and later uh I and the hanging with here
we strange the lower bound to the
average case proving that and guilty
cannot be half past one over polynomial
approximated by polynomial size as
cellular circuits
and the
so approximately I mean over the uniform
distribution
so later uh I and the thing and the
Williams and Ryan we proved that e to
the MP cannot be half past or single
here right
so we prove that even empty cannot be
half plus
um inverse the exponentially
approximated by the final size as the
other circuits for all sufficiently
large input lenses so it's almost every
valuable
in this talk I will try to give
alternative proofs of this worst case
and the average case results and also
our our show some new theorems
so uh first time is something about
William's original proof uh it kind of
interact in the sense that it's
essentially approved by contradiction
so a very very rough summary goes and
follows you first you assume the the
lower bank is force that you assume an X
is containing as a zero then you try to
use that together with some non-tribute
algorithms to contradict the end time
hierarchy
uh of course this is like a very very
rough you can see the the Williams
original paper or like the the summary
my in my like yesterday paper
for like more information or you can ask
her right here so our motivation if you
guys can we have a more direct proof so
of course it's hard to Define what it
means by direct but uh intuitively you
want to like avoid the proof background
addiction and the and the
background addiction yeah and the hope
is just that the the new proof can be
like either a bit easier to have to
follow to understand yeah
so so yeah
so now let's move to the uh a new result
antonimization Centric perspective on
the algorithmic method uh
so he has all roadmaps for proving and
kill peace not in X zero it's on so
first we'll show our lower bounds for a
certain subclass of marine answer so
I'll Define money as a uh in actual
slides against I say zero so this is
unconditional lower bound saying like a
circle
it's harder foreign
next I will just randomize this double
class into mqp
so now the hard language goes to nqp
then we have the angle Pinot in Etc
lowermost
yeah that's that's the that's the
two-step Prime for improving encopy not
negative
as fast let's have some some uh some
technical details so but let me try to
explain the both of them
yeah I'm trying to hide that so it's
okay so the first step is not okay I
need to recall what's the ma the malays
are a randomized version of MP I say I
randomized version because you can also
think about am but the am is much harder
much harder to the randomize so we are
going to focus on M8
so
um with their language L is in m a if
that's that polynomial time uniform
algorithm v v stands for battery fire
such that so given an input X we will
get some witness Y and plus some coins
and then you X is in the input like that
exists our proof of weakness such that
we is going to accept that with high
probability over its randomness and if x
is nothing else then for every possible
proof it's going to be rejected the
probability
and as you can see if left no no coins
are
then this is essentially then this is
just empty right
so this is the definition for Ma and
then we are going to
Define a subcast of ma
by looking at the verifier complexity so
we will Define m a sub c to say that a
class of four
a complex
zero or ac0 or like some complexity cost
so we say
well with MMA sales to Define talking
note the surprise of ma such that the
verifier V at the mid polynomial size
potentially nonline from six circuits
foreign
[Music]
circuits
so this is the first result so this is
the subclass this is the super class of
ma we are going to focus we are going to
be look at so in this case the base is C
zero circuits
in size could depend on K but yes yes
yes yes
foreign
additionally require that it's kind of
comfortable but
potentially not only from six seconds
and that's uh yes
I think you can also maybe if I just ask
them if you need more inspired like a
way in our paper we already consider the
when we had we only found six okay
okay
so this is the most important definition
of the of the of the talk if you
understand this then you'll be fine
okay so next oh now we have a lower
bound what do we want to do
uh now now we're going to apply some uh
some previous previous work
so
yeah yeah in Chinese
uh 2020 we prove that this class m a sub
8 0 is actually contained in Infinity
often and QP
so in other words for every L computable
by m a sub zero to M A with exerted by
fire that's another language L Prime in
non-demonistic quasi polynomial time
such that for infinitely many n so this
is the I O with IO means for infinitely
many N L and L Prime equals
um equal on in bit inputs
so
I actually saw some photo of the authors
and
I guess that looks different from those
okay so so okay now it's very clear what
what we are going to do next right we
have the lower button for Ma
we have the randomization we just put
them together
so what can go wrong
combining them together you should have
a you should have a good nothing at a
zero but uh
the first theorem is only uh of course
if only it is almost everywhere then you
are good but it's very hard to prove
almost every log on before I made so the
serum one only stays this L is hard on
infinitely many ends
and the generalization
here also on these days a generation
only works on infinitely many end and
these two result don't talk to each
other so it's very likely they are not
going to help not going to agree on the
same
so it's very likely these two sets
although both of them are infinite they
have no no intersection
right and in that case yeah you actually
have nothing so for example this is L
Prime can be something like unless and
which which is not agree with L it's
just empty
then then maybe you only have empty
language at the end so you so that's the
problem
so what if the the damage and only works
for those input lenses where your
language
is not hard
okay any question regarding this issue
what is the on the right hand side this
is basically theorem one but with some
Rush
uh
yeah but why did you discuss the right
hand side this is a restriction that you
fix
uh
that's that's the that's the
that's a statement and made the
basically is being IO mplp means right
right
but
ACC
uro and m a
h
what was the question how different are
they I mean do you expect them are they
is there any reason to think that
they're not equal I actually I mean in a
grandchild basically a vehicle I think
they possibly
but uh you need to have very strong
charity to show that that's the problem
yeah okay yeah okay yeah once your analy
is about I think even and it's the
same answer you can raise up the sub DNS
yeah yeah I think that's very subsidious
problem yeah because for MP you can
always make the verifier to be as far as
you know yeah and uh so here the problem
is you cannot be randomized if you can
still
make equals MP now of course
MP and then the verify can be just made
to be like a straight and happy yeah the
questions
yes so let's just ignore the right hand
so I just concentrated
don't worry about
okay you do that yeah last time yeah
yeah yeah that's actually how the
program will go like you want to
okay so okay I'm like
the focus on listening you will try to
make this larger
and uh that for following movies and
William that's actually a way to
strengthen zero one here so that the
hard input lenses and the the
randomizable impedances these two sets
have an infinite type intersection
I'm not going to explain this because
it's because it's pretty technical but
the
the idea is that although you cannot
make it almost everywhere you can make
it almost almost everywhere so yeah
that's the that's the name invented by
Miranda Williams yeah
yeah okay so so I mean
like forgetting about this technical
issue we we have this
we can we can now prove Enclave is
nothing as a zero because we have we now
know that the hard language after
generalization will still have
infinitely many hard impedances right so
we have the lower one
so okay so this is like the alternative
perspective on the uh all the result so
can we get some new results from this
perspective sure is this a direct proof
here we were asking for a more direct
proof is it what you're looking for this
is
so can you say something about the
previous
uh sure so the the the well actually I'm
going to talk about it at the end of the
vote but maybe that's the benefits
so okay so what what's new without Canon
can we following this uh New Perspective
so first uh Williams actually into the
pool an act has no sub steps still
experience yourself as a little circuits
yourself
okay what does that means it means you
have three of G and it's maximizer and
you have two of them which is so
expensive so this is an
Improvement on Williams original
of course the open question can you
improve it even further to like stop
exponential and this is even open for
Sigma 2x I believe
yeah
yeah so see Williams talk about this
same questions we actually get new
dynamization for S6 zero so recall that
the previous work shows m a sub I say
zero is contained in IO and QP if you're
using my bucket as a proof system it
says that a randomized proof system with
that with an ss0 verifier can be
simulated by a non-demnistic proof
system with a deterministic verifier
with quasi polynomial running time and a
quasi polynomial problems
please
open questions for arbitrary circuits
I'm sorry yeah yeah
I guess I just want to connect the women
yeah
polynomial
so the runtime is still quite a
polynomial so here is end time guess
denotes the the subclass of nqp where
you only make polynomially many
non-demonies yes
so the third and time and a guess so
time and a guess so we actually we
improve this ma subscribe
IO and time gas plus polynomial
polynomial
so this is kind of interesting because
you actually get polynomial proof
although the running time the time to
verify that is still quantity polynomial
and why it is interesting because this
actually can be used to prove new lower
bounds
so
so recall this is the language developed
by non-feministic machines with running
time T and the non-denominium bits
atmosity
we prove that nklp with super polynomial
non-deminine feeds is strongly average
case hard against I say zero so write it
out end times polynomial and to the
alpha n Alpha is any super content
cannot be half passed on predominally
approximated by accidental circuits
sorry what is super polynomial
non-determinism beats oh it just means
anti-gas to teleport to particular
polynomial and enter the alpha Edge so
so yeah I mean for any like uh super
constant function of
the super polynomial
s
[Music]
yeah yes so now you have uh oh you
explain what it is
so I'm saying that now you have a
smaller class to which you can talk
about right
the previous things
because previously the the 90 million
can be quite polynomial but now it can
be any sort of normal it could be into
the long story yeah that's it right
so let's includes on previous work by
nickel which he only proves that worst
case law about and by also my general
work with honey which we
and improve the strongly every case
lower bound against for nqp
and you may already guess how it is
proved right because if you look at
seven three
I mean the if the if I it's very clear
how do you it may become medical how do
you approve 04 so I'll explain how to
approve certain form
so so how do we improve how do we
improve this uh Stronger lower bounds
against I say zero it also clarify like
why we want to look at this
generalization perspective because
so because we previously will have lower
bounds for some for ma for some for some
kind of ma like I say zero and you
generalize that into entropy so to make
it strongly average case you simply make
a improve every customer bounce against
M right
after generalization you have everything
slow about
I mean because the dimension keeps the
keep the language
and the tool to make this NLP smaller or
to do is very simple just just plug in
the pathogenization
so now now it becomes into the Super
normal it's because previously the lower
bank is like a fixed fixed
into okay for every K so the generation
becomes into the Samsung polynomial 90
million bits
so here I'm saying that with this
perspective kind of sharper in the sense
that if you improve the amateur Bond you
get better you can you get you directly
get better lower bound you will improve
the generalization you also get better
lower bound
anything any questions
how many times do I have
[Music]
so let me now move to the truth
actually
so first I will
I'll try to talk about my how do I put
the new improved lower Bound for an X
against XA zero
or I can see you can view it as a
randomization Centric proof of the of
the next
zero
so what's wonderful
half exponential side as well as a
little circuits and uh this way a notion
means you compose G twice it's like
Central
and uh we are going to make use of the
previous generalization as We Know M a
sub I say zero is being non-coming is
the io and QP now it can immediately a
quality polynomial time
okay and you now you do a simple padding
you will just pass this ma to like a
select Financial
and then the Uncle P just becomes an X
because it's quasi polynomial of Select
Financial is actually still so expensive
but I'll just write next
but it is clear it's a very simple
padding argument
but now now we have the generalization
what you want to do is actually I guess
you so what we're going to do is to get
a lower Bound for for this class for the
left class
then you try to get a lower Bound for
the right cards
so first we start with a very simple
diagonalization it says to do a job and
time it's nothing Infinity Alpha and job
and size
uh that may be some like polynomial here
but I'm just trying to mix things simple
simple to write
so geez again
so this is too bad you just enumerate
every possible job inside circuit it's
probably like to do a Japanese Square
but yeah
the key element here says that assuming
e has G of n size it's a little circuits
then e is contained in and made time
let's say 0.50 itself
so here I the it means that the verifier
runs in Japan time and the verify can be
implemented by job and size as a little
circuits
okay if you have a kilometer actually
the proof just just follow usually so so
you just do a padding so
this means to learn times being and made
time is the zero Japan and now you by
padding is actually it actually means
you replace this and the red end here by
tripping
so now you have time to put a jump in
it's containing anime time Etc G of
Japan
this is an example
can you see the pointer I don't know
it's good enough
it doesn't work very well
anyway so uh okay so now you have the
so just combine this diagonization and
this padding element you what you got
you have ma
Express amount of time it's nothing
infinite Alpha job and size right
because the now you have time to do a
job and it means it's containing Ma
Japan
and also another job of G of T of n is
expensive
and also we previously we can randomize
this class into Infinite Alpha and X
now you put them together what you get
you get an access not in size jumper
so a crucially
you need that
almost everywhere a lower bank here so
this language is always hard so even if
you you only have if another
organization the results you get is
still high
and this is essentially follows iqw
yep
but you need to use like some like a
it's a refined version of the iqw
argument
so in conclusion look at the kilima just
assume he has jump inside those circuits
so in conclusion either e has no C of
circuits which means we are good we have
the lower bound or an X is nothing
which is actually stronger
so I mean but in both cases we have the
lower boundary one and actually it's not
in
self and Stuff Etc
is a proper almost always
yes compared to the Lao bouncing other
proofs this is like a stronger because
it's almost so so bad are you paying
because it's exponential it's also
conditional you're assuming it has
strawberries
this is not direct this is a proof of
confusion so
yeah
so if you look at this two conditions
together
okay that's uh okay one slide proof uh
okay I still need to prove the killer of
course
so you assume e has different size XL
circuits you want to show so you can be
simulated by and many times I say zero
uh Dublin
so the proof is actually very simple
what do you do first you we will take a
very efficient in PCP with an XL battery
fire say the princess and the viola 14
paper and we apply this to some language
in e
next this
statement he has jumped inside
accidental circuits are actually already
implies that whenever X is in the
language
that's a PCP witness and has G of X size
X is circuits
how to approve this so the idea is that
so for this language L you construct a
different language L Prime such that our
input X and I you output the ice the ice
speed of the
PCP within this for x
that language is also in e so you can
you can apply this condition
so now if you look at this second
condition says whenever X is whenever
their variable axis in L that's a very
short very small
is very simple you give an input your
guests are
creepy poof
of a small circuit instead of a circuit
they run a you run the s05
that's the language that's the
that's the oh this Japan should be
probably just
that's uh
yeah yeah so yeah yeah exactly is very
simple you just come you run the the
positive verifier which is a zero and
the the verifier cost the the
second you guessed the overall
complexity is just actually zero does
this require anything special about the
uniformity of the ac0 verifier uh
uniform
yeah I mean it's good
oh actually it kind of needs to be
uniform as long as you have you have uh
if it's okay you have a like a very fire
I mean it's only implementable by
not only if I said that's okay but you
don't know that's actually fine
but I mean it's not very important okay
if I understand correctly is a witness
that is computable by a small
sickness
okay the idea is like this so uh so now
we have this language here it's in E you
define new language
business
and uh now so let's I claim this new
language L Prime
is also in e
why because if I take an input X to L
you will in external time I can decide
whether X is L that is don't do anything
that is in L I run some PCT construction
to find the activity with news that
output is acid
so and the importance to the L Prime is
X and I is of om speed because the
creative proof is Expendable size the
overall thing still in E and then you
use this condition just L Prime is being
a prime small circuit then just line is
implies the
estimate
yeah there might be a figure inside of
the G or something uh yeah I'm trying to
you know I'm trying to make it yeah of
course I can write a very very like like
a rigorously but that would be a pain to
look at so yeah yeah yeah that sounds
like a this is this is probably that's
some this should probably be T of T of
three x I guess you understand those are
three here yeah but I mean anyway that's
some minor detail
[Music]
um
this for this slide
no
no no
uh okay it continues to be a random
function like uh increasing time
convertible that's it
um
this may not work yeah
[Music]
so yeah so this this Lemma does not
require you to be so expensive the only
thing which requires an exponential is
here
because you want this to be to be uh
contained in the the thing you can
randomize
but this required to be some experience
yeah so the kidama is it works for any
reasonability yes
and also it works for any renderable
Fair class
is that here this is true like if it's
actually zero like and say one it's fine
yes how many minutes do I have
15.
okay now let me try to uh by the way any
questions I mean before I move to the
uh disaster some something else
okay
so now I'm going now I'm trying to
expand uh the the I think Antonio's
question like it sounds like you spend
how do you prove this theorem uh well so
actually I'll prove something
um more General also for most of the
Class C C can be anything like a
we have very constant k m a sub a602 of
C has no n2k size physicists
so you say is X is zero then there's a
little two at the top time matter so you
get you get what you want
and then why is x02 uh I'll try to
explain
and whose input are output of a layer of
C sub circuits so you have a they say
there are two at the top and it costs
many system function at the bottom
so previous a previous work in which is
implicit in
1999 shows that to the same thing except
that this episode 2 is tt0
so our goal here has time to our
particular is two is too large from us
if we want let's say zero so we need to
improve this
the previous work but uh let's recall if
state level is content death for the
number of size circuits consisting
entirely of majority bits
but that is at opposite uh the majority
it
so so okay but so let's recall like a
another review how the previous
uh steering works and the wife is a zero
so roughly speaking in the previous
paper uses a piece based complete
language with a tc0 instance checker
foreign
such that
on input X you only query M tweets all
Curious by m with Oracle has learned
exactly the same length of x
that's like our same lens is
if you are given the correct Oracle else
of n then you output the correct answer
with probability one so m is
probabilistic
so aliens the Restriction of L to empty
inputs
but for every input X and for whatever
Oracle M given to all given to the m
that Port is either the correct one for
some like I I don't know the sign with
probability with all the rounding
probability
and finally if we say l is say instance
checkable if M can be implemented by a
family of non-adaptive C Oracle circuits
so the previous work gives um
Christmas company language with that tc0
instance checker
is the definition clear
so the previous work proves this result
by using a piece based company language
that is still available instant
checkable
and let's recall definition of ma
okay any type of how the verifier in the
defined hard anime language because it
works the black goes as follows first
you treat your witness why
at that polynomial size say circuit
system y
next you simply run the instance checker
with c as an oracle
and uh okay okay actually that's it
that's the how the that's how the ma
language works
and the over complexity as you can see
is the instant Checker uh cause the
Oracle C which is the title of C
so our goal here is to improve the
clever above to x02 to prove cn1
and that's exactly what we did we we
prove that that's a piece based complete
language that is they say there are two
instance checkable zero two downwards of
reducible and isol two weekly error
correctable and also and it's also
payable the the other two conditions are
important for the for other stuff but uh
the most important thing is it's a
little too instant checkable
so you plug we plug in this language
above
to the
into the previous proof you you guys
didn't want
um
yeah okay I guess they still don't
understand like how the how language
Works maybe I should uh I can't write
something
so so maybe let me let me let me say
more detail on on how the proof goes so
you have this piece based complete
language
hello
and we know it has a ac02 instance
checker
so now you have now there are like a
you consider two cases
the first case
is that it's ill it's actually
campaign in peace as poly
I'm following request online proof which
so I'm not putting the almost almost
everywhere version which is actually
required to resolve the infinity awesome
version I'm just trying to focus on the
verify complexity
so in this case
what I mean it means oh sorry this
should be
it should be
L is zero
so if this is the case what that means
means
um I can I can actually show m a
sub I say zero
this space is contained
why because I can because I know this
this language L is a zero so I can I
have polynomial size Etc circuit I can
run I can the ma algorithm can guess the
impedance and then algorithm can guess I
see a little circuit for L sub n and run
and run run instance checker
this gives you this if you look at the
definition
is this this actually computes elsewhere
but in this case we know that in P space
we can do diagonalization
so of course uh amazing zero is not in
uh into the case size circuits for every
case
and this proof crucial to use the fact
that the very the instance checker
also runs in something lower than Exit 0
because the overall verifier is going to
be an instant checker
occurring the gas circuit
and now consider the second case
L is nothing
zero
so let's make a simplifying assumption
let's say
let's say let's say we want to pull
suppose we want to prove and may 860
is not in
to the case size
zero
so let's say the language is computable
I
I don't know into the K Square size
let's say zero
but not
until the case at XL zero
so in in this case what you can do is
very simple you simply use this
use these circuit to compute the
language L and now the language L not
now you can put language
zero I simply guess the the circuits and
then verify and then then compute
so now you immediately have an amazing
error is not in into the case that let's
say zero so of course this this
simplification is too strong with the
idea is that because this is not true it
means uh that infinitely many input such
that error is super polynomially hard
and for those for those hard inputs you
actually can to do some padding to make
it exactly until hey hard and then you
guess and verify and uh that's basically
the idea yeah
any questions
foreign
[Music]
the most part of the paper is trying to
figure out a way to
that several components so it's either
complicated but I think the most
important thing is to realize that you
only need to do polynomial interpolation
for constant development which can be
done in HCL too if you only work with
fields of characteristic number two
so yeah so the institution around
several things but the bottleneck is
actually another interpolation and
previous food
that principle just call like a teenager
for another time another definition
algorithm but uh
that's a way to to like uh to modify the
language so I'm gonna need to do
predominal integration with constant
development which can actually be done
in Excel too if you work with like a f
it yeah yes
is
it because just see that that's two
thresholds
yeah the proof that was because
that's probably very hard
so yeah it's no overhead since we need
to do something for another
interpolation
foreign
just a general result
the general question this is how to work
out there when you try m a
one-sided Arrow
oh
looks with ma for ma with my head Arrow
yes but what you wrote is the tournament
uh yes but uh okay of course yeah but I
I said for you if you look at this like
the foreign
foreign